en france les jurés de la cour d'assises
dès mineurs du rhône sont en
délibération depuis plus de trois ans
maintenant et le verdict concernant le
procès de patrick dils devrait tomber
dans la soirée
ce matin la parole était aux avocats de
la défense ils ont demandé
l'acquittement
mais l'incertitude demeure à lyon
stéphanie perez et jérémie drieu pour
ses dernières paroles avant que la cour
ne se retire patrick dils hausse le ton
c'est la première fois je suis innocent
je suis désolé de vous avoir fait
souffrir dit il aux parties civiles
mais je n'ai pas tué vos enfants
aujourd'hui je voudrais vivre
je veux que tout ça s'arrête je suis
fatigué pour le clan 10 l'heure de
vérité a sonné la fatigue se lit sur
tous les visages plus que quelques
heures d'attentes
après quinze longues années de procédure
et trois procès
dans cet avenir espérons que ça va bien
se passer
je pense quand même que pas refaire la
même faute qu'ils ont fait avant
vous êtes confiant on est confiant
parce que si la bile faucon la même
faute alors je ne comprends plus rien
tour à la justice pendant cinq heures de
plaidoiries les deux avocats du jeune
homme de 31 ans jettent leurs dernières
armes
bertrand becker défend 10 depuis 15 ans
ayez le courage de reconnaître l'erreur
judiciaire messieurs les jurés
patrick dils est la troisième victime
innocente de ce procès et m florent de
poursuivre le temple judiciaire sera
ébranlée mais il se reconstruira tout
seul
ne pensez pas au scandale ce que je
souhaite c'est pour ça que j'ai insisté
sur ce point c'est que les jurés du
courage s'ils ont du courage et une
intime conviction je pense qu'ils l'ont
il sera acquitté
j'espère qu'ils ne seront pas les
gardiens du temple et qui ne coûteront
pas les sirènes leur disant pas de
vagues pas d'erreur judiciaire
condamnons la 15 ans libre demain tout
le monde est content non parce que il
nous faut une décision courageuse et
d'essai au courageux ces décisions
d'acquittement devant le tribunal le
comité de soutien de patrick dils a pris
place pour attendre le verdict
les délibérés ont commencé à 16h30 les
maman d'alexandre et de cyril elles ne
sont pas venus cet après midi elles ont
la certitude que dils est coupable et
qu'il doit être condamné